there is a mountain village
in southern russia called carata where
residents
work and pray and tend to verdant
gardens
but there's one patch here that's gone
to seed
its owner kazeem nurmagomedov hasn't
touched it
in the past three years that's when his
son
marat went to syria to
the feeling of bewilderment wasn't his
alone
it was shared around the village after
30 residents
left to join is the authorities
did little but kazim decided to track
his son
down
in 2013 he slipped into syria and found
his youngest son
training with other jihadists he then
tried to persuade him
to go home
against
[Music]
finally convinced his son to leave but
he had to find somebody
to get marat out
son hasn't made it back to russia
instead
he lives in the shadows in neighboring
ukraine
and we asked if we could go and see him
his father led us to his flat in a
run-down neighborhood near odessa
and gave the signal to open up the door
marat lives on his own but he's not the
only ex-jihadi
in this country community activists told
sky news
there are now four to five hundred in
hiding here
we met the next day in his bedsit a
former fighter in an army
that once numbered thirty thousand
marat's got a laptop
but he lacks a valid passport and risks
arrest by ukrainian police
so i asked him why he didn't go back to
russia
janaka
the 33 year old has time to pray
and reflect he told me he's finished
with
is are you a security threat
to this country to the rest of europe
uh
we met another ex-jihadi under the trees
in a local park
he joined islamic state as a
seventeen-year-old
and fought in syria and iraq four years
later
he's on the run in southern ukraine
i thought
right still there is a risk that former
militants
decide to fight again and for extremists
from russia
and central asia ukraine makes an ideal
base
they can speak the language and make
arrangements to leave
they move into ukraine to get a new
documents a new passport
and they know that it is easy uh to make
it in ukraine because
we have a lot of corruption hubs
if you have a real ukrainian passport
you can
make a biometric passport and then you
move to
europe for example back in southern
russia
where it has spread about mr
namagamedov's expertise
he's become something of a consultant to
desperate mothers and fathers
looking for their children
this man's son joined is last year but
he hasn't heard from him in months
he's looking for contacts and advice
kazim says he will try and help but he
told me
they're unlikely to see their son again
while dozens left this valley to fight
in syria
none have returned
but there are survivors like mr nomega
madoff's son
and the way they're dealt with may
determine the direction
of the terrorist threat
as for kazeem well he says the flower
beds and vegetables
will have to wait john sparks
sky news in southern russia